il a à peine 22 ans il joue au basket
aux états unis depuis trois saisons dans
le championnat universitaire il
s'appelle jonathan ouégnin il a été
formé au club de l'entente le chesnay
versailles jusqu'en 2007 anthony rech la
rencontre et quelques jours après la
finale de nba opposant san antonio à
miami nous sommes à côté d'un basketteur
yvelinois qui a été formé à versailles
et qui a tenté sa chance
outre-atlantique il ya quelques années
je veux bien sûr parler de jonathan
miens bonjour à toi merci de nous
accueillir dans ce stade le stade sans
soucis à versailles comme je disais tu
as tenté sa chance aux états unis il ya
trois ans explique moi un petit peu ce
choix en fait d'avoir d'être parti là
bas en fait c'est sûr voulu partir car
la balle le basket et les études son
relais en fait quand je la barge dans
une école par un club donc pas forcément
les classes le niveau scolaire de suivre
donc
c'est toujours le basket s'est les états
unis donc toujours voulu partir là bas
c'est le rêve pour tout basketteur qui
se respecte de jouer un jour peut-être
en nba bon pour l'instant tu rn6 et le
format universitaire oui bon ça va pas
que tu avais meilleur joueur de toute
façon que tu as été formé je le disais à
versailles tu as fait tes gamme
à l'entendre le chesnay-versailles tu en
garde un bon souvenir du club berlinois
oui un très bon souvenir je vais là-bas
de plus un jeu mais après deuxième année
pousse à jusqu'en cadets et c'était
vraiment de bons souvenirs on faisait on
travaille beaucoup de gamme des choses
qu'on va pas forcément aux états unis
mais qui sont vraiment et social pour un
basketteur on viendra justement après
c'est sur cette différence entre le
système européen et américain mais je
voulais d'abord savoir un petit peu ton
parcours comment tu es arrivée outre
atlantique entre le chesnay et
versailles et les états unis que s'est
il passé
j'ai fait un camp à dijon j'ai été
recruté pour aller jouer à besançon qui
ne savait pas qu'en pro b les avances en
informations
je suis allé
ensuite dans l'effectif cadets sur plan
de france je me suis entraîné avec les
professionnels l'inde après besoin 53
donc j'ai un espoir proie et l'année
suivante j'ai eu la chance de partir
dans une école j'aurai des vidéos du
mois que ce prêt cette ascension elle
est assez impressionnante
tu as vite progressé depuis ton départ
de versailles tu as presque 22 ans
aujourd'hui
tu as quelques années en entier comment
tu as trouvé le système américain la ba
ba j'ai toujours un enfant je travaille
beaucoup c'est à dire que je
m'entraînais beaucoup vendent tout seuls
et la basse et surtout basé son travail
donc ça me plaît forcément et le style
de jeu est plus rapide plus athlétique
et c'est mon type de jeu dans ce match
ça colle tu parlais de l'importance
écoles basket
qu'est ce que tu fais à côté du basket
aux états unis par je suis en train de
passer mon master 2 d'informatique et
mon myners business donc on a des cours
tous les jours les entraînements le soir
à côté de ses études il ya évidemment ce
championnat universitaire on parle
souvent en europe que c'est le meilleur
championnat universitaire du monde aux
états unis
ça a l'air d'avoir une arme pourtant
c'est incroyable dans ce pays fait
vraiment que je bosse ordinaire il ya
des matchs devant des milliers de
personnes
cm faisait que la proie en france c'est
à dire qu'il ya la march madness en
masse hélas tous les états unis devient
flou pendant un mois ils regardent que
le basket pendant un mois c'est vraiment
quelque chose qu'il ya pas un homme à
côté de ses championnats américains tués
aussi sélectionné tu as déjà été
sélectionné en équipe nationale mais pas
en france puisque tu joues pour la côte
d'ivoire
comment ça s'est passé ces sélections
c'est quoi ton meilleur souvenir
peut-être mon meilleur souvenir c'est
vrai que l'année dernière on a joué
contre l'équipe de france en france à
toulouse
je jouais fraude
c'est tellement beau souvenir y avait en
face tony parker qui n'a pas joué mais
il était là avec boris diaw ronny turiaf
de colo franchement c'était un beau
souvenir
cette année tu as été nominé dans un
concours assez particulier aux
etats-unis c'est le concours du plus
beau dunk
qu'est ce que tu as fait dans ce
concours quel est ton résultat j'ai fini
dans le cadre des années j'ai perdu en
demi finale contre le vainqueur qui
était à syracuse
les gens ont voté pour moi c'était
vraiment sympa surtout en france et j'ai
eu beaucoup de soutien c'était vraiment
cool
est-ce que ce championnat est tu penses
que ça peut être un tremplin pour la
suite de ta carrière
ça peut aider oui c'est sûr je suis en
deuxième division c'est pas la première
mais bien sûr que ça peut aider
il ya des joueurs qui ont joué avec moi
qui joue maintenant professionnels donc
c'est sûr que ça peut être quelque chose
intéressant pour le futur ton futur
qu'il envisage comme en nba
est ce que c'est encore jouable ou plus
un retour en europe par exemple à otto
rahn je pense que ce serait bien je
pense pas l'habitude de la nba pour moi
c'est un rêve je pense pas je pense
plutôt à jouer alors en europe ou
ailleurs dans le monde
dans un championnat professionnel
comment tu l'as vécu cette finale entre
san antonio et et miami d'une finale
très intense match 7 en finale on peut
pas rêver mieux
les deux équipes ont joué jusqu'à la
dernière minute c'était pour un
basketteur tout basketteur franchement
c'était le meilleur final que j'ai
jamais vu moi personnellement sur ces
deux équipes finalistes c'est tu as des
modèles j'imagine oui bah mon joueur
préféré qu'ils jouent actuellement c'est
dwyane wade de l'area de mes amis donc
c'est vraiment il a fait un bon dernier
match donc j'ai tellement contents et
ils ont gagné très bien merci beaucoup
je n'attends de nous avoir accueillis
ici à versailles et on te souhaite tout
le meilleur pour la suite parce que
m'avoir accordé cette interview